allo ragazzi ragazzi ho bisogno della
vostra attenzione cagate minatti con
questa cosa è seria ho trovato questo
gioco è veramente incredibile
prima di cominciare di lecco al volo la
pagina di steam di questo gioco merita
della sicuro alcuni dottori di un
ospedale psichiatrico in provincia di
torino hanno segnalato la scomparsa di
un collega alla polizia che devo dire
cominciavo ragazzi io ci sono nato in
provincia di torino è questa la cosa
gravissima sono emozionatissimo nel
giocare un gioco horror ambientato dove
sono nato io in provincia di torino c'è
sicuramente la mia scuola media di cosa
del caso di trattare qua ci sono delle
scarpe bella sta a casa comunque allegra
ma teoricamente sì devo andare nel
basement dore chiuso bisogno della
chiave va bene c'è suo aiutami tu non so
dove sia la chiave però prima di
controllare il piano di sopra ghazi
controllerei perbene di sotto visto che
ci sono altre vie che non ho visto tipo
questa mi chiamo è stancato il
personaggio pensavo che fosse successo
qualcosa
madonna che ansia non comprerei mai una
casa posta fare qua sotto le scale
orribile permesso
va dove vedi sopra da questo punto non
c'è non si può aprire nessuna porta di
sotto andiamo lì sopra dobbiamo trovare
la chiave per la cantina e devo trovare
in tutto questo col dottore scomparso a
tipo in ascom donna che orribile stato
di out ma le luci proprio non funzionano
ma come chiuse ma corsa chiusa e luci
non puoi chiudere le luci a chiave non è
normale se c'è un altro piano di sopra
qua calmiamoci non non c'è niente di cui
aver paura state tranquilli non devo
spaventarmi di questo gioco andava tutto
chiuso instamatic gioco cioè l'unica
porta verde alla gola per entrare in
casa ma com'è possibile parlare a torino
le teniamo le porte aperte in casa credo
è chiuso bisogno della chiave non è che
si può aprire il menu gusta la per il
menu perché ho trovato una scatoletta
piccola prima c'è un tasso per avere
meno ci sono i tassi di spiega che non
ci sia in opzioni tasti controles
inventario control bombe
il numero uno eccola qua aprirà a ecco
ecco la chiave perfetto dove aprì la
scatoletta lo sapevo
noi non teniamo mai le chiavi dentro e
i barattoli non pensate male di torino
ragazzi ma teniamo un sacco di utensili
per cucire dentro le scatole di biscotti
quello forse anche noi
noi sicuramente permesso che bella
questa casa allegra mi servirebbe per
cortesia un qualsiasi four con schivo
che nora galli bile speriamo che mia
mamma non vedo a sto gioco se no la cosa
più horno di tutto sto video è proprio
questo per questa cosa qua bistecca
buona un ottimo ma te lo credo che
quello impazzito e psichiatra mica se
vive in una casa così c'è qualcosa fate
intro pacchetto di sigarette le vecchie
rolo preso lo prese ce l'ho ce l'ho con
le sigle siga scuse share e sega questa
si apre da quando quest'anno portare
corridoio insomma niente sigarette medi
uanto smoke singole o medi note bat
esami nate di thank you ok non c'è
un'altra chiave dentro le forze rolle di
3i per cosa torino a f8 pc 9 b b 7 c a 8
di a 9 che vuol dire ragazzo ragazzo
sentito la voce corribile non sono pazzo
io camera che corri bill è mai sentito
proprio del genere il biglietto del kakà
no no no no no è successo qua non ci
sarà quindi non c'è niente di tutto ciò
scusi satana è chiuso frega niente va
bene al suo posto posto la [ __ ] ma
che via via via via fuori dalle palle
fuori dalle palle
rumori o riba poi senza un motivo cioè
macchie di sangue a terra e c'è qualcuno
che sta facendo una perenne scoreggia
non solo sentire però non ho capito il
service toccandone mutande è da un po
che non prendeva alza così per un'ora
e giuro questo poi è veramente fatto
bene anche perché non sai quando
succederà qualcosa mi chiudo qui dentro
nel dubbio
[ __ ] va stavo dicendo no però dai
ragazzi fate i seri nora gara è orribile
e orribile tutto ciò orribile permesso
macché how che fate anche la lap dance
figo dai ragazzi allora sono dentro la
cantina tutto tranquillo cioè solo del
sangue di sopra ma alla fine magari la
vernice vedi noi a torino siamo abituati
a pitturare per terra e voi non lo
sapete ma lo dico io la fattura la
fattura ci sono anche dei milanesi o no
no no no no no no no no no no no cos'è
cos'è sto bordello ma che è anche una
scatola di si muove oddio c'è un gatto
dentro tranquilli ma [ __ ] cazzo
era un topo ma va a cagare va tronchesi
meraviglioso no si è aperto
qualcos'altro mentre prendevo le
tronchesi non so cosa via via via fi e
le balle ma allora le tronchesi
teoricamente dovrebbero servire per
rompere quell'affare no ragazzi mi inviò
cagare addosso poi colui che corre ci
manca solo questo dio santissimo che
anzi è orribile
cosa è successo qui allora si era
parlato di mercato prima addosso non
l'ho dimenticato già meno male che me lo
riuniti calo tra l'altro posso usare per
aprire queste in realtà è perché qua c'è
un lucchetto che si può tranquillamente
tagliare eccolo tanto che con con che
sound effect me lo stai dicendo d'aver e
non c'è niente premi chiuderei
volentieri qua dentro e sarei qua
perfect couples ho bisogno di un
cacciavite a stella però perché si vabbè
ci manca solo quello guarda già un
miracolo che ho trovato un coso dei
tronchesi mani maggio al cappio
vabbè andiamo ad aprirla tutto ce n'è un
altro di si cosi adesso rumore qua che
sento come questo che qualcuno aprisse
una porta con sesto rumore via via via
via via via teoricamente dovrebbe
dovrebbe nuovo verbo aprire questo l'ho
aperto giuseppe i conti alla scaletta
preoc adesso posso arrivare in cima
all'armadio anche se non è proprio
quello che volevo ma non fa niente
andiamo in cima all armadio è questo
quindi posso mettere la scala qua
ok ok ci sono quindi
la foto di camilla insomma mi manchi il
tuo papà ma che carino mi riprendo la
scala perché non ho capito cosa me ne
frega di camilla adesso va bene tutto ma
qua sento satana infermi nelle orecchie
ci manca solo che io mi preoccupi di
camilla per adesso va bene tutto per la
scala per raggiungere altre altre
postazioni quindi posso usarla tipo
anche un buon uso ok ma manca manca o
che l'ho trovata la scaletta perfetto
apri cacciavite vedere
eccolo al caso libertà è la da melo
grazie ciao la frazione stato bello bene
ho trovato il cacciavite a stella vado
ad aprire il corso col cacciavite e poi
non ho idea però vabbè mi si sbloccherà
altro immagino visto che ancora sta
chiave questo codice che posso
utilizzare che non ho ancora capito cosa
mi servono però va bene cacciavite a
stella let's go cacciavite spalla si va
a ragazzi come non posso fare e non è la
stella fra cacciavite immagino che io
devo usarlo per aprire questo perché
sarà o e quindi non ci credo
magari
aiuto che schifo i topi che schifo
ma cosa
[Musica]
ok
ma